you've said like you never got to go to
college right do you regret any of that
you do you do you say gee wonder what
that would have been like what I could
have learned academically maybe it would
be a fun time no I have this massive
chip on my shoulder about that you do
because when you started with Twilight
which is a defining moment you said that
was like a college education and I don't
think it's the education social yeah
it's like hanging out with all those
kids yeah that was like the period of
time where I was like you know drinking
too much beer and like rolling to class
like you know cross-eyed was it so much
fun in the camaraderie I mean not only
were you fallen in love with Rob on the
set which by the way I think is the
biggest mistake an actor can make it was
just it was just the director was even
nervous because the first time you guys
kind of the auditioned you together or
you would already had the part but they
had they put you together to save the
chemistry there was immediate chemistry
between the two of you yeah yeah it's so
weird like like actually being honest
about this is like it's been so heavily
consumed and it's like I have this fear
that people would assume that maybe I'm
like you know it's kind of a tension eat
like oh cool you're still like pushing
that narrative or whatever it's like no
I've actually never been allowed to just
say what happened right because I was so
self-conscious about seeming like an
attention-seeker
like so trying to or taking advantage
yeah exactly the fact that you guys were
dating and you know people I mean I we
were together for years that was like my
first you know hey love yeah I mean like
I was super in love with my high school
boyfriend super super [ __ ] in love
with him but me and Rob are like a
little older and it was just like go
gung but he's a charming guy he's really
he's the best and you know that movie
especially the first one the way you
played it
and maybe you know it was just perfect I
was super aware that we were doing like
a teen movie and I had never done that
before I'd done like very over serious
kind of like dramas pretty much my whole
life and then then this I was like I
wanted to do like a cult II weird
indulgent just like full-blown you know
it's weird to use the word girly now for
anything because I don't know what that
means are we talking about what is that
like it is a girly role it is the
traditional it's yes it's Julia Roberts
in Pretty Woman when she you know sees
Richard Gere superpowers it's Lois Lane
it was seeing Superman
it is a girl it's a traditional
Hollywood girly role that's why it's
even more brave that you came out with
your life and lived your life with
tentacley because people want to see you
over and over again as that that
romantic girly role